[Music]
so hi everybody I'm going to present our
conversation in the breakout session
with don bosco at risk and home link
network NGO which basically work at the
forefront of finding missing children in
india as was presented yesterday the
missing children are a big problem that
there's a lot of run away and lost
children's on the street and don bosco
home lake are at the front front of the
fight of trying to help them in
particular just don't in the dom bosco
organization by themselves in over the
last 10 years have found almost 300,000
children on the streets and try to help
them by finding their parents and if
they don't manage to find their parents
and if they're placed with them then
actually take taking care of them in the
long in the long term and so out of
those almost 300k missing children they
have actually successfully managed to
find the parents of one hundred and
seventy thousand children which is a
huge impact in basically reuniting these
kids with with their parents and having
a normal life so how do they do their
work essentially a commlink has these
front liners which are people going to
the train stations the bus stations the
markets likely locations where children
can get lost or hang out if there are
Runaways and they're looking out
essentially for for kids that look like
they don't have an adult with them and
approach them and talk to them trying to
identify whether they need help once
they encounter a lost child they
interview them in the beginning as a
motivation they might give very limited
information and this primary initial
information is related to social workers
that are in the office trying then to
use that limited key information to
quickly find the parents and without
information essentially what they do is
they don't google searches about like
school names or other landmarks that
they might mention
a village named etc and then from there
if they find anything call the local
police department try to see whether
there's a missing person report etc
setter so it's a very time intensive and
very kind of detective work so to say
with a very extremely limited
information so in particular one
important thing is basically being able
to match a kid back to their parents if
they're lost is extremely important for
their quality of life and long-term
effects and essentially also even the
time that it takes to match time is also
important so the longer time that they
spend in the system the bigger impact
that has like so psychologically and
emotionally on the child in the long run
right so our goal is can we help Don
Bosco and Homelink to to maximize the
matches and minimize the time in which
they managed to do that so we identified
three particular areas in which AI can
help the first one was using historic
data in order to identify key child
information that facilitates matches so
as they have a lot of historic data what
combinations of key pieces of
information increase the likelihood of a
match the second one is can we use
historic debt in order to predict
hotspots in space and time so that they
can allocate more of those front liners
to be at the right places given the very
limited resources that they have and
finally a more long-term suggestion is
how can we create a missing child
complaint submission system right now
there is really no unified system like
that it was mentioned a lot of people
don't feel comfortable when going to the
police and even if they do the police
don't have a system that's accessible by
the NGOs right so can we create create
something for the parents to report
their missing children that's accessible
and inclusive and most people will feel
comfortable using so on the first point
so again here using the historic data as
I said it's almost 300 K samples of data
for me samples of kids that were
actually found for which they have this
process of the information that they got
whether they managed to match the
parents or not we want to
we built a predictive model that tells
us which subsets which combinations of
features like age clothing maybe village
name or school name which of those
things together were the most effective
in class creating a successful search
right and so as they're doing this they
are actually interviewing the kids over
time so there's even like this
sequential effect where they they will
ask more questions
so with this predictive model what we
can do is we can use it to add to give
guideline to the interviewers of what
questions to ask like if they if they
got for example the village name what
other extra questions should they insist
on in order to most effectively
triangulate the parents right
so maybe village name and XYZ together
is much more effective than village name
and other things that they might ask so
the second one is also as I already
mentioned there's very limited resources
there's actually a lot of variation in
them the number of missing children that
are likely to be at any particular time
in any particular place in time for
example there's a seasonal variations
there's holy days that intensify the
number of lost children and there's the
cloaca festivals for related to
particular places so can we just mind
this rich historic data set to to map
where these hotspots are and help them
advocate strategically there they're
resource allocation we believe that this
is something that is very quite easy to
do and so that would be our our first
kind of data exploration exploiting the
readily available and low-hanging fruit
in applying in blank' I and then the one
that I mentioned before is going to be
our second second thing that we'll try
and in the longer term we're going to
try to create this missing child
complaint submission system that again
has to be accessible inclusive there's
most many parents that have low literacy
and that are not using the internet to
go and create
an online profile for their kids and
there's also many languages in India so
from that perspective we came up with
two things first of all there can be a
there should be some way of them just
leaving a voice message and in that case
we can use AI to translate whatever
local language they are using to English
and transcribe it and then pass it into
an actual child record that is
searchable when you know a child is
found and additionally if the parents
are able they can upload an image or
send a text message with an image of
their child and then we can use AI to
match to parent the parent submitted
photos to photos of the children found
by the NGO as I mentioned there is
already a lot of additional valuable
data over ten years over almost 300,000
missing children found by by Don Bosco
home link and they already have the data
with the with the time the other's world
was found and the key pieces of
information that were gathered for each
child like gender age clothes coding
details etc and so we're going to use
this data to - in our first two tasks
some of the ethical concerns in the
broader scope of this operation that we
identified is if we're trying to create
some kind of system that works across
institutions how can we resolve in the
institutional issues and standardization
of sharing the data in order to be able
to facilitate this matching with all of
the data available across all the
stakeholders and players in this field
there was some discussion about using
biometric data so in with respect to
that we have to worry about local low
compliance and finally we want to make
sure that whatever we do we want to
secure the data from these misuse by
traffickers so
you